can the Greek government be trusted to
actually do what they are promising to
actually implement in the coming weeks
months and years
I think those are the key issues that
will be addressed today
we haven't concluded our discussion so
we will continue at 11 it is still very
difficult but work is still in progress
the view of the institutions is that if
the Greek government commits to more
reforms in the future if you'd come it's
also too now implement reforms on the
short term and there is the basis for a
possible opening of negotiations on a
program via via the North bussola let's
a millisecond on an illusion of item
within the median golden compass moods
moon fever now ha paternalism for we can
reach an agreement tonight if all
parties wanted
we've come a long way but a couple of
big issues still are open so we're going
to put those to the government leaders
and it's up to them
Oh
today we had only one objective to reach
an agreement after 17 hours of
negotiations we have finally reached it
someone can say that we have an
agreement los alamos clearly my kicks
minister k mishra telus pepsiman regime
earn a degree keys remote EK lees ter oh
yeah sinfonia pufa costena todo hasta
ahora stop ova dis ql nikolaos my
boorishness in a kiss nevada